on sunday night the san francisco 49ers
will be hosting the green bay packers
and this is something i noticed earlier
in the week courtesy of
nickwagnervspn.com
yeah the 49ers are embarking on a
stretch of three games that could end up
being historic at least in the super
bowl era for the winning percentage of
the teams that the 49ers will be facing
right now the next three opponents
packers raven saints all have won 80
percent of their games
if that holds which means the ravens
need to beat the rams on monday night
the saints need to beat the panthers on
sunday and the falcons on thursday night
then all three opponents will be at or
above 80
that will be the first time that's ever
happened this late in the season in the
super bowl era for the 49ers to have
back to back to back opponents of that
magnitude now look they had some easy
opponents early in the year it all kind
of balances out but i'd much rather
space out
those three teams then have to take them
one after another after another
especially with all the injuries the
49ers currently have yeah yeah
definitely uh yeah this is gonna be some
tough stretch here now i think they are
a really tough matchup for the green bay
packers i do the green bay packers
defense not being very good you know uh
they have the tools on the 49ers defense
to stop and aaron rodgers as far as
great pass rushers on the edge only have
to rush four you know can drop seven
into pass coverage all the times if they
just don't let devonte adams and aaron
jones beat them which you know we've
seen the 49ers run defense is arguably
the best in football you know so it's
special
from from those lines too but you're
right the health problems are concerning
they definitely are um and there's you
know like we talked about last year or
last hour there's a lot of familiarity
with the coaching staffs kyle shanahan
worked for mike pettin lafleur's in
green bay of course he learned football
and a lot of things from the shanahan
family working under them
i do think the 49ers are the better team
but yeah with some of the the health
concerns uh it does kind of even the
playing field here to where it could be
a great game on sunday night
and for more on the 49ers health
concerns here's head coach kyle shanahan
on wednesday rattling through the
various injuries that his players
currently are suffering from
injuries for today
um not practicing will be breeda
ford robbie
kittle
debo
emanuel sanders and joe staley yeah
everybody who's not practicing will be a
game time decision the other guys
i think will have a better idea here by
friday
so that's matt breida george kittle
emmanuel sanders debo samuel that's all
on offense and you're throwing joe
staley the left tackle deford on defense
they're kicker robbie gold
and they're all game time decisions and
another thing shanahan said which i
thought was kind of surprising the fact
that the game was flexed to prime time
yeah actually may help some of the guys
be available that those four hours isn't
that weird those four hours could be the
difference between a guy being able to
play and not being able to play
definitely yes you know
i hear this a lot from coaches you know
just because when you got to play that
let's just say one o'clock pacific time
game
you know the day starts at a pretty good
hour for nfl football players you're up
at 7 7 30 in the morning and you're
getting going and of course you know
early in the morning you never feel
great especially as a football player
you know it takes a little while to get
you know all the kinks and you know get
the oil blend going through the joints
and get everything moving the right way
and all those type of things so a little
extra time a little extra maybe
exercises and rehab can allow guys to
start feeling good for you know what
would be what a five o'clock uh pacific
time type kickoff around that around
that range so that is an interesting
angle but the big thing is those
offensive uh injuries to me debo samuel
and emmanuel sanders have created a
really special tandem a receiver for the
san francisco 49ers samuel uh debo
samuel is like a uh he's a running back
who plays wide receiver physical over
the middle breaks tackles can beat you
deep emanuel sanders can do everything
route running and it's just a
well-rounded awesome receiver and then
when you don't have kittle who is the
best player on their offense man that's
tough and that's really where they had
the great advantage against this green
bay defense that stinks there's no other
way to say it it's 28th in football they
can't stop the run at all their interior
defensive line is just not good you know
they're middle linebackers they're just
not good and because of that it makes
mike pettin have to do some things in
coverage that i don't think he wants to
do and they get exposed in pass game too
because they're doing things they don't
want to do so uh it takes away a great
advantage for the 49ers to have those
injuries and you know like i said i
think it levels the playing field in the
match up a little bit i do think the
49ers been healthier clearly the better
team than the green bay packers then
there's always the 12 effect with aaron
rodgers
and and a guy who has just become
forgotten in that offense is marquise
good one with sanders and yeah and
samuel both injured then maybe it gives
goodwin a chance to do something he's
got 12 catches in eight games this year
and he was a healthy scratch at least a
couple of times so kind of a strange
year for him but maybe an opportunity
coming his way if both debo samuels and
emmanuel sanders can't play
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports